what is a point by serial correlation
Point by serial correlation is a special
case of Pearson correlation and examines
the relationship between a dichotomous
variable and a metric variable what is a
dichotomous variable and what is a
metric variable a dichotomous variable
is a variable with two values for
example gender with male and female or
smoking status with smoker and
non-smoker a metric variable is for
example the weight of a person the
salary of a person or the electricity
consumption so if we have a dichotomous
variable and a metric variable and we
want to know if there is a relationship
we can use a Point by serial correlation
of course we need to check the
assumptions beforehand but more about
that later how is the point by zero
correlation calculated as stated at the
beginning the point by 0 real
correlation is a special case of the
Pearson correlation but how can we
calculate the piece and correlation when
a variable is nominal let's look at this
with an example let's say we are
interested in investigating the
relationship between the number of hours
studied for a test and the test result
was passed and failed we have calculated
data from a sample of 20 students where
12 students passed the test and eight
students failed we've recorded the
number of hours each student studied for
the test to calculate the point by
serial correlation we first need to
convert the test result into numbers we
can assign a score of 1 to students who
pass the test and a score of zero to
students who failed the test now we can
either calculate the Pearson correlation
of time and test results or we use the
equation for the point by zero
correlation a X bar 1 is the mean value
of the people who have passed the test
and X bar 2 is the mean value of the
people who failed and one is the number
of people who passed and two the number
of people who failed and N is the total
number but whether we calculate the
Pearson correlation or we use the
equation for the point by zero
correlation we get the same result both
times let's take a quick look at this in
data tab here we have the learning hours
the test result was passed and failed
and there the test result was 0 and 1.
we Define the test result with 0 and 1
as metric s is usual for dichotomous
variables if we now go to the
correlation and calculate the Pearson
correlation for these two variables we
get a correlation coefficient of
0.31 if we calculate the point by zerial
correlation for learning hours and test
result with past and failed we also get
a correlation of 0.31 just like the
Pearson correlation coefficient R the
point by serial correlation coefficient
rpb also varies between
-1 and 1 with the help of the
coefficient we can now determine two
things one how strong the correlation is
and two in which direction the
correlation goes the strength of the
correlation can be read in a table if we
have a coefficient between
-1 and less than zero there is a
negative correlation thus a negative
relationship between the variables if we
have a coefficient between greater than
zero and one there is a positive
correlation that is a positive
relationship between the two variables
if the result is zero we have no
correlation often however
starting from a sample we want to test a
hypothesis about the population we
calculated the correlation coefficient
from the sample data now we can test if
the correlation coefficient is
significantly different from zero thus
the null hypothesis is the correlation
coefficient R is equal to zero there is
no correlation and the alternative
hypothesis is the correlation
coefficient R is unequal to zero there
is a relationship before we get to the
assumptions here is an interesting note
when we compute a point by serial
correlation we get the same p-value as
when we compute a t-test for independent
samples for the same data so whether we
test a correlation hypothesis with the
point by zero correlation or a different
hypothesis with the t-test we get the
same p-value if we compute a t-test in
data tab with these data and have the
null hypothesis there is no difference
between the groups failed and passed in
terms of the variable learning hours we
get a p-value of
0.179 and also if we calculate a point
by zero correlation and have the null
hypothesis there is no correlation
between learning hours and test results
we get a p-value of
0.179 in our example the p-value is
greater than 0.05 which is most often
used as significance level and thus the
null hypothesis is not rejected but what
about the assumptions for a point by the
original correlation
here we must distinguish whether we just
want to calculate the correlation
coefficient or whether we want to test a
hypothesis to calculate the correlation
coefficient only one metric variable and
one dichotomous variable must be present
however if we want to test whether the
correlation coefficient is significantly
different from 0 the two variables must
also be normally distributed if this is
not given the calculated test statistic
t or the p-value cannot be interpreted
reliably thanks for watching and see you
next time